let's go medical marijuana is already a
multi-billion dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this
look most people will tell you as Alden
walked on the amendment but even a
complete idiot will tell you Neil
Armstrong did it first and do you know
why he went first positions hedge openin
hiss because you push bezel durand the
[ __ ] out of the way and seize history by
the ball sack I'm satisfied
Brook man you're in some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy dude then cash
boy
no I'm saying you're poor poor tomorrow
you can apply to Mexico what we want you
to hand-deliver the weed pill formula to
the lab windows BS and I'm not supposed
to touch the minibar but I'm going to do
it you know I don't even care anyone I'm
doing it what a [ __ ] cry-baby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out
gonna caffee we sold a little product to
the cartels but when we cut them off
they got a little angry
I know a guy I've tracked down dictators
if I can find a guy in middle man what
do they want
injected a microchip I need to keep
track II can't scare me the tales of the
big bad cartels I don't things work not
in Mexico that's Harold Harold he didn't
go Gala Bingo
you really believe in God of course I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in God I guess I kind of do
but not things you can just have to get
better for you trust me
I have good instincts
you